how is the syndicate doing i know you
had started to do some deals there you
were oversubscribed on the first two
you got two or three thousand people
signed up in the first two or three
months it was
pretty impressive to see how quickly it
grew and obviously there's unprecedented
interest now from the public in
syndicates it wasn't always like that
people
right what is the syndicate i'm not
interested uh now everybody wants to be
in them because they're seeing all these
syndicates hit home runs but tell me how
that's going
it's going really well we we did it from
june to november to kind of just see
data and try to learn
what we could about the behavior of the
syndicate
and then we did our first deal of this
year
i think we kicked it off at the
beginning of april the end of march
and so we have two deals going so we've
done about a dozen deals
oh wow um about two million total um
so it's anywhere from a hundred thousand
to five hundred thousand per
deal and now with our new fund
that is a 506 c so i can talk about it
uh with our new fund
we are going to be at least for the
beginning part of it matching
um or putting a certain amount in
to kick things off because before we
were actually it was our fun it was our
like everyone else was our lp
i'd put a personal amount minimum in to
everything just to
be part of it um but we didn't have all
this extra capital
yeah so now um that's part of the model
and i think that
that just shows people even more
obviously you
if you want to be in we should be in you
know so
it's just yeah you have to get in the
game right like if you were putting in
some amount and then
the that was one of the original
criticisms on angellist
when i started there were people who
maybe had rich networks but maybe not
were not rich in terms of capital yet
and they would be putting in 5k or 2k a
deal yeah but then there would be 500
000 would come in and people were like
oh that's
that's that's the not right incentive
structure whatever and then people
started racing funds and in fact that's
what i do i have a fund
100 of my deals go through the fund and
then maybe
40 or 50 wind up getting syndicated if
there's room for the syndicate and if
the founder wants to do it not all
founders want to do it absolutely um
but it's it is a wonderful approach
because people get to what i love about
doing it i don't know if you've had this
experience now that you've done a dozen
of them
when you write the deal memo you're like
okay this better be a
good company i i wonder what the
reception is going to be
oh sometimes i have like five times as
much interest in a company i think
this is a risky one i'm really you know
i'm really
you know swinging for the fences here
and then other ones i'm like this is a
no-brainer to me
and it does you know just whatever
compared
to yours yeah yeah so i absolutely and
um
uh it's at backstagecrowd.com and you
can sign up but
every time we do it it's so important
and so special because
things are moving really fast to your
partner about earlier before we were
making 25 000
investments in companies and at the time
absolutely was so
like significant to us it was the best
we could do and now
we are you know we'll put something
through the syndicate and
wake up the next morning and there's a
hundred hundred thousand that's been
committed
and you really just start to really play
in the
in the big leagues um and and ultimately
we'll be making million two million five
million dollar
out of the fund but i'd love this part
of it i don't ever want to just skip
this part of it because it just feels
like
can you can you believe it six years ago
people were laughing at this idea
yeah and now you know everyone sends
their deals to us
and we have to like stop people at the
door it's very interesting it's like a
very
um surreal situation
yeah it it really can get heady
we've had a hard time keeping up with
all the deals and we now have
7 500 accredited investors 600
joined last month wow that's great and
it's bonkers like how quickly these
things can fill up the issue i have now
is
we have to get bigger allocations
because when you send a 400 000
allocation now and 1.2 comes in that
means
and 300 people want to invest not just
you know the max is 250.
you got a lot of bad feelings right and
yeah yeah
we're not there yet we don't have that
problem yet jason
well i mean you're trying to attract you
yeah yeah as i told you personally you
you
started off much further along than we
did and our first deal calm
i put 50k in from our fund and 328
thousand if i remember correctly from
the syndicate so you started thinking
about that as a fund manager okay i had
50
thousand in there it's a five million
dollar company got one percent okay now
i put another three hundred and okay now
we've gotta we're talking seven percent
of the company come becomes worth two
billion
oh my lord now you got a hundred million
dollar plus position
which is what it turned out to be again
is this isn't your book called
like the yeah it's like how you took a
hundred thousand turn into 100 million
and you do that twice yeah twice and
yeah we'll probably we'll see with robin
hood or some of the other ones if that
happens again we didn't get to syndicate
robin hood unfortunately we just got to
put a 50k check in yeah
tell us about this 506 c for your new
fund and how are you raising the new
fund are you doing it um
with the shore fund management or you're
doing it with um
angel list or just with a law firm yeah
it's it's internal law firm this is a 60
million dollar
uh target and we you know
it's uh things get out of hand very
quickly and people get a lot of opinions
about stuff so just
call everybody calm down it's a 60
million dollar target just like every
favorite white man you've ever heard of
and ventured they have a target
they go after it sometimes it happens
sometimes it doesn't sometimes it takes
a week sometimes it takes two years
we're you know gonna hopefully have our
first uh
close by the end of may and we have a
very structured what we're gonna invest
out of that what that will be that's
what we're telling founders
and um it could take 18 months to raise
this you know life is what it is
in the meantime what's been so rewarding
is to be able to tell lps you know
we are we're going to the crowd for for
a lot of things and they're
listening and they're reacting and the
crowd is now the biggest
competitor to early stage vcs and to lps
in a way